my life flashed before my eyes
this phrase is generally used when
someone is referring to a close
encounter with death an assumed end of
their life but in truth our lives have
already flashed before our eyes
in that moment when you awaken to the
world and light strikes your redness for
the first time the shutter of your life
opens and you begin to take everything
in From This Moment On In One continuous
flash you create your picture trying to
get everything you want in frame trying
to get your smile right your hair right
your position right the people right the
setting right
but there was only so much time with
each second each day each year slowly
but surely the shutter closes until
eventually it closes all the way
when you're young and you've only lived
a few years time seems like an
infinitely spanning open plane it
doesn't even really exist yet you
understand the concept but it can't hurt
you
at some point though forever turns to an
age to a number to a ticking clock and a
changing calendar a 15th birthday a 30th
birthday a 60th birthday that open plane
has a horizon and it's moving towards
you as you age more and more time seems
to go faster each New Year weighs less
in relation to the whole one single year
when you are five is twenty percent of
your entire life that same year when you
are 30 is just three like a drop in a
bucket though the same size each new
drop appears less noticeable to the
whole not only does it seem like an
increasingly fast pour but as the bucket
fills things also begin to submerge and
dissolve away within it your youthful
innocence your openness your propensity
to have fun your friends your family
your hopes for something new and
exciting
eventually you reach a moment when you
realize your bucket is becoming more
full than empty and you're looking back
more than you are looking forward you
find yourself longing for your past for
how life once was or perhaps more
accurately how life could be
[Music]
on one hand Nostalgia is beautiful it
shows us what's been great about our
life but on the other it is a cruel
deception it hides from us what is true
about our life
right now this moment this day will also
become a memory but the truth is most
memories are forgotten almost
immediately and when your future self
looks back at this phase of your life
you will almost certainly not remember
this moment or this day this includes
all the things you are worried about sad
about stressed about bored and unexcited
by and if you are not careful you will
look back on this phase of your life
still having not learned nostalgia's
trick
every phase of Life carries its baggage
its problems its stresses its tedious
routines its positives and negatives it
is the curse of nostalgia to look back
on the past and see only the Highlight
Reel and feel none of these things since
past problems have likely long since
been resolved or dissolved away into
irrelevancy you do not notice or feel
them when you look back in their
direction and you do not consider all
the moments and days that you don't
remember at all but just like they are
here they were there in every part of
your life
they are always there
as you age you let go of certain things
with some things you don't have a choice
with other things you have a choice and
choose to let them go and some things
you hold on to long past the point of
them still being good for you letting go
moving on adapting that's growing up but
perhaps more important than what you
hold on to is how you hold on to what
you do
in the words of Sam Harris it's not so
much what we pay attention to it's the
quality of our attention
life isn't some progression towards some
Grand perfect Transcendent version of
itself it is a continuous churning of
days filled with little moments with
hopefully a few highlights here and
there
the real loss though will be to not
embrace the whole image to not notice
and appreciate as many little things as
best you can to seize the day isn't to
do anything differently per se but to
consider what you do differently to see
each moment as the moment of your life
where everything is because in truth
each passing moment however Grand or
small however trivial or exciting is
your life and all your life will ever be
the playwright George Shaw wrote youth
is the most precious thing in life it is
too bad it has to be wasted on Young
Folks
we can never obtain our youth again once
it is gone but we can obtain the wisdom
to realize the mistake we might have
made in youth not realizing what we had
and we can refrain from making it again
right now while we are still the
youngest we will ever be
eventually you will do everything for a
last time there will be a last time you
see your friends your father and mother
the last time you sit quietly next to
your partner and watch light from a
screen flash against your faces a last
time you drive your car stand up on your
own brush your teeth laugh cry feel a
breath of air flow into your body and if
you could at any of these moments you
would with enough Cosmic intensity to
light the Stars long to do them another
time but you won't you can't moments
don't come back and right now you don't
know how many more you have left
if there is one thing we ought to try to
learn with age it's how to accept and
embrace what our life is the little
moments in the big the sad and the
joyful it is all one big flash each
phase of our life merely a different
subject in the same image if we wanted
to look a certain way if we want our
life to feel a certain way the time to
get in frame is now
because sooner or later the time is up
the shutter closes the picture has been
taken
[Music]
oh
foreign
thank you so much for watching this
video was sponsored by blinkist blinkist
is an amazing app that makes it easy to
actively learn from more books in a
shorter amount of time it works by
condensing over 5 500 of the best
non-fiction books and podcasts across 27
different categories into around
15-minute explainers that can be both
read or listened to even while offline
one of the greatest yet simplest joys in
life is that sense of awe and wonder
that we can experience when learning
something new and eye-opening expanding
one's perspective and knowledge equips
one to expand the breath of one's
moments and blinkist makes it easy and
enjoyable to fill as many moments as
possible with new discoveries and
insights for example in just 10 minutes
you can learn from The prominent stoic
philosopher Seneca about stoic ideas and
methods of handling the nature of time
in the title on the shortness of life in
which you'll learn what Seneca argued
for is the best way to use one's time to
both leverage it and appreciate it as
much as possible
in the words of Seneca life is long if
you know how to use it blinkist also has
a great feature called blinkus connect
that allows all premium users to share
their account with another person
letting you share the books you love
with someone close at no additional cost
use the link in the description or scan
the QR code and you'll receive one free
week of unlimited access as well as 25
off and annual premium membership the
free 7-Day trial can be canceled at any
time within the trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
foreign